les habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines sont venus chercher leur
composteur mise à disposition par
l'agglomération avec un kit incluant un
bio seau un tiers de nos ordures peuvent
être compostables être acteurs de
l'écologie une démarche importante pour
ses habitants
on s'aperçoit que le fait de de polluer
de consommer de plus en plus à des
impacts est vraiment significatif au
niveau de l'environnement je crois que
ça y est il est temps de trier ses
déchets et de mettre en place du
compostage dans mon jardin
lors de la remise du matériel des
conseils étaient transmis aux futurs
utilisateurs notamment sur les déchets
acceptés vous préparer une soupe il vous
reste des épluchures il vous reste des
vues du vert de poireau et les choses
comme ça tout ça vous pouvez le mettre
dans votre composteur la principale
précautions à prendre
ce sont les déchets d'origine animale
ont la viande le poisson les corps gras
tout ça on conseille de ne pas le mettre
dans le composteur depuis février 2019
dans l'agglomération 700 composteurs
individuels ont été distribués une
participation financière de 25 à 30
euros était demandé une démarche
également possible pour les quartiers et
résidences l'agglomération fournit le
matériel sans participation des
habitants
qu'est ce que nous apporte plus exotique
à la résidence l'arbalète des prêts à
montigny le bretonneux
un petit groupe de voisins s'est formé
pour accueillir trois bacs de compostage
de 800 litres une fois que le premier
bac le bac d'apport est plein on vient
dé verser la totalité dans le troisième
bac qui est le bac de maturation et
ensuite ça pourra servir aux espaces
verts à la pelouse ou aux gens qui ont
des bacs à fleurs par exemple les
résidents ont pu voir émerger la
transformation qui s'est faite entre ces
trois bacs mais aussi l'évolution de
leurs liens maryline didier est tony se
retrouvent et échangent régulièrement
autour du compostage vecteur de lien
social dans la résidence